welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and why are Kang the Conqueror and
Thanos both so worried about
overpopulation one using Infinity Stones
to snap half of all life out of
existence the other burning trillions of
lives from countless timelines are these
really the best ways to serve the
greater good you mean there's a better
way let us break down each of these
villains Master plans to understand why
Marvel's two biggest bads are both so
agoraphobic and how specifically this is
set in stage for Avengers Secret Wars
hey by the way if you're going to
WonderCon we're going to be hosting a
panel on Friday March 24th at 2 30 pm
and please subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive where I recently dove into
what is really going on at Marvel
Studios so in Avengers Infinity War
Thanos explained to Doctor Strange his
whole fear of overpopulation and how it
started with his home planet of Titan
too many Mounds not enough to go around
and when we faced Extinction I offered a
solution genocide but random passion is
fair to rich and poor alike they called
me a madman and what I predicted came to
pass yes Titan was destroyed and Thanos
was left with the worst case of I Told
You So and he channeled that frustration
in a very healthy way going Civilization
by civilization killing half of the
population of each the Zio Beret the
corbinites that has Guardians and after
Gathering the Infinity Stones everybody
and yes this motivation is very similar
to that of Kang the Conqueror who in
explain to Jenna Van Dyne my variance
throughout the Multiverse play with time
like children but I saw How It Ends I
saw their chaos spreading across
realities universes colliding endless
incursions I saw the Multiverse and it
was dying all because of them so I took
control and by took control King means
he vaporized his neighbors and entire
planets killing trillions all to avoid a
horrible horrible alternative incursions
which should be fair are pretty ugly
according to Reed Richards and
Multiverse of Madness an incursion
occurs when the boundary between two
universes erodes and they Collide
destroying one or both entirely one of
these post-incursion universes was in
the process of oozing up into the sky
and surrounding the sanctum sanctorum
there was a field of Bones field of
Bones is actually what the Field of
Dreams really should have been called if
it was that haunted by baseball players
so between overpopulation within one
Universe an overpopulation among several
universes really what is the best way to
handle that crisis well Thanos started
with massacre in civilizations one at a
time but as infinity stone Quest
represented what you could say is a bit
of a Humane shift a relatively gentle
and quick Dustin followed by resources
hopefully being reallocated so that the
remaining half could Thrive never mind
the chaos in the streets the group
therapy sessions everyone has to have
it's all worth it because we got whales
in the Hudson and PB JS for Natasha yes
meanwhile Kang's timeline eradication
multiplied this on a universe by
Universe wide scale and in fact seemed
to borrow from the 2014 variant of
Thanos from the third active end game
who wanted to erase the entirety of the
universe and start over remember that as
long as there are those that remember
what was there will always be those that
are unable to accept what can be but
would either of their plans have worked
statistically speaking Thanos wiping out
half of Earth's people would only set us
back population wise to where we were
around the year 1970 which I know is
pretty crazy right if you look at the
population growth curve for the past 50
years China and India got real busy
since the summer of love so if you were
to just call Earth by half if the
current growth Trends would just
continue from that reset Point well I
guess you could argue they would be
stunted by the whole shock of the blip
and might take some time to recover for
the normal procreation rates to get back
on track but either way roughly within a
single lifetime we'd be right back to
where we were so what was Thanos
thinking was he planning to snap every
50 years or maybe to get someone else to
do it for him after those stones
inevitably wore him out if his entire
life led to that decision do you think
he would have thought it through a bit
more or looked at some basic population
growth statistics that takes five
seconds to Google meanwhile Kang's
approach to this is equally spotty like
what's to stop a future non-kang buriat
scientist from discovering Multiverse
hopping too and creating a dynasty of
Jerry's or whoever and getting along
real great and creating more incursions
it just would have made more sense for
Kang to prune himself in all of time
travel technology out of existence I
just hope no one else is smart enough to
ever discover the secrets of it now I
grew up on Batman and James Bond but as
much as I love the idea of a
gadget-filled belt I don't want to leave
the house every day with a bunch of bull
okay stuff taking up precious pocket
space all I really need are my wallet
and my keys and ridge has me covered on
both fronts for 10 years now Rich has
been making minimalist gear for those of
us pocket Warriors who don't like the
idea of carrying a sack of stuff with us
every time we leave the house their
wallets are slim but still have room for
up to 12 cards and cash and fit in any
pocket you've got with room to spare
plus you can choose a design that suits
your Vibe Ridge key cases fit up to six
keys and keep them all tucked away so
you don't have a bulky gently lump in
your pocket every day how somebody
didn't think of this the day keys were
invented I don't know right now Ridge is
celebrating their 10-year anniversary
with a massive sale so it's a perfect
time to upgrade your pocket game just go
to ridge.com new rockstars right now and
you can save up to 40 through March 24th
that's ridge.com new rockstars to save
up to 40 between now and March 24th now
if Thanos and Kane claim to be so
focused on the great so good
why like what responsibility do they
actually have to it why can't they just
enjoy their life lives are there some
horrible actions that are Justified when
the alternative is too Unthinkable to be
allowed to come to pass it's like the
trolley problem if you watch the good
place you know what I'm talking about
the Charlie problem is an ethical
thought experiment that asks whether an
onlooker should save five people from
being hit by a trolley by diverting it
to a track where it only kill one person
if this sounds morbid it is something
they are currently coding into
self-driving cars so pay attention
Thanos is influenced by malthusianism
which is the theory that a population
will always increase faster than food
supply can keep up ultimately leading to
Wars famine and general suffering so a
bit of population control might not be
the worst thing in the world meanwhile K
might subscribe to the ethical theory of
consequentialism which basically says if
the consequence of an action is
ultimately positive then any method used
to reach that consequence can be
justified and Kang seems to be looking
at the problem of multiversal
overpopulation through the lens of a
scientist as a problem that he thinks is
a clear-cut solution one probably
arrived at by a lot of heated Roundtable
discussions by the Kang Dynasty Thanos
on the other hand seems to be looking at
the world's problems through a more
religious lens ebony ma was essentially
his high high priest hear me and rejoice
you have had the privilege of being
saved by the great Titan you may think
this is suffering it is salvation the
universal scales tipped toward balance
because of your sacrifice Danielson the
black order wanted to convert people
into their philosophy everyone who
argues with Thanos and infinity War if
Thanos tries to debate them on the
merits he wants to have a grateful
Universe Kang meanwhile ain't shopping
for a thank you he only explained
himself to Janet because she
accidentally saw his mind Kang likes to
do his snipping in the shadows now we
must also ask does this kind of
population Colleen work remember there
was that episode of what if what if
t'challa became Star-Lord where we saw
an alternate Thanos who seems to have
come around to a different way of
thinking I'm a big enough man to admit
when I'm wrong t'challa here showed me
there was more than one way to
reallocate the universe's resources that
way being growing more food with things
like the Ember of Genesis ultimately the
best check on overpopulation other than
you know a responsible civilization
growing itself sustainably good luck
with mankind getting to do that the last
line of defense there is really nature
itself I know it sounds like I'm making
a case for famine flooding and
ecological disaster which is easy for me
to do when I live on High Ground out of
the way of a flood plain but I think
most people even most vulnerable would
prefer to live in Haven Hills Alabama to
Thanos or Kang deciding what's best for
them is to turn them into Ash Kang
considers increased incursions to be the
death of the Multiverse but forgive me
is that not just natural selection at
work for every field of Bones there's a
universe that won that multiversal
incursion and benefited from the
crossover to have you know rainbow
clouds pizza balls and Patrick Stewart
don't we kind of want a bunch of
universes smushed into each other isn't
that oh good X-Men here and isn't this
how we get Battle world and Avengers
Secret Wars selective incursions that is
clearly where all this is headed Kang is
just building on the work that Thanos
started we know Kang and his variants
are aware of Thanos the TBA had a drawer
full of Infinity Stones a multiple
choice question that used Thanos as an
example film stocks showing Thanos
murdering Loki and they knew all about
the Avengers time ice plot against
Thanos we're not here to talk about the
Avengers what they did was supposed to
happen you escaping was not now I've
said before on Tony Stark and benching
time travel to counteract Thanos was
perhaps the first piece of technology
that would lead to Nathaniel Richards
breakthrough in the 31st Century so he
needed that history to unfold as it did
but I think Kang's biggest note for
thanos's plan was that it was too random
a coin flip for every person Kang's
enemy is an overpopulation its
population growth that he cannot control
Kang's Ultimate Enemy is chaos he
practices selective pruning and so when
he brings all the Marvel heroes and
villains together in battle world and
Secret Wars including his agoraphobic
predecessor Thanos he will be letting
them fight it out to decide who gets to
stay in the MCU but it will be a game
that he's the master of hey a reminder
to subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and support us by grabbing some
merch at nerd riot.shop you can follow
me on Instagram and Twitter at a boss
follow me rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign